i think maybe i have a way to put kevin
in danger without putting kevin in
danger well hello there raymond teach me
kevin
and i am detective jacob peralta he
didn't have anything else to wear so he
just switched
he understands
we have ourselves a pygmalion situation
exactly a pig mailman situation right
it'll be okay well it'll be okay let's
get started yes let's get started it's
getting worse spot on kevin look raymond
a yellow-crusted warbler a greyman a
yellow-crested warbler no you're too
excited the warbler's a common bird and
then i said which metamorphosis kafka or
ovid
i loved it he loves it oh so that's the
joke no you tell it oh okay
so a professor walks into a rare books
collection no you've ruined it now it's
not funny look remind a yellow-crested
warbler look raymond a yellow-crusted
world ugh not excited enough they may be
common but they're still birds the 92nd
street by had a wonderful symposium on
just that topic that's it you're getting
it ah
don't say cool instead say indeed oh
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
that's weird look raymond a
yellow-crusted warbler yes that's the
right level of excitement for such a
bird you've captured the essence of
kevin you've done it correction i've
accomplished it indeed indeed indeed
indeed
i will not be selling red to swag and
you can go tell your client he now has
100 problems is it jay-z
no but since you're not taking the dli
shouldn't for me that my client will be
moving on to plan b opening his own
store directly across the street from
yours across the street
what kind of store is it gonna be he's
calling it tommy's closet it's a
high-end second-hand clothing store
where parents can rent clothes for their
teens tweens and priests as well as
babies toddlers grown-ups and olds but
that's my idea and my name so i guess
only domino's is allowed to sell pizza
now it's called capitalism mr haverford
and you are about to get a free lesson
only this free lesson is going to cost
you
so it's not free
you're right that was confusing
this lesson will cost you good day
this sucks but i have to admit it's a
pretty baller move
you sure this isn't ditty
it is ditty i do it's not diddy
had to do it one last time before all
this goes away for good so what are you
offering me now nothing it's over that
was our last idea
good
soon all your precious humans will be
gone
yeah that's too bad
well congrats bud you won see in a
billion years
when the humans evolve again i'll be
right back at your throat you traitor i
mean yeah i know that's why i said see
in a billion years
wait
i'm gonna do the evil speech now if you
want
since the dawn of time good and evil
have waged a furious battle stemming for
this feels stupid if you're not gonna
fight back how do you not have another
plan you've always had another plan
what's wrong
okay fine
gonna make me admit it
fighting you is the most fun i've ever
had
i mean you know
you corkscrew your first eyeball and
you're like man i can't believe they're
paying me to do this
by the trillionth it's like
i should have just been a teacher and
then you go and get the warm fuzzies
about your little humans and something
something changed
i was having fun again
i'm not sure i'm ready for that to end
ah hello captain hello kevin so uh
here's an update on sheamus thanks to
our little operation the fbi was able to
roll up his entire organization they're
saying it's gonna be one of the most
significant ricoh prosecutions they've
ever done amazing it's over now he can't
hurt me or kevin thank you for titting
my tat well thank you for tatting my tit
and you know in a weird way i'm gonna
miss our little house yes and in an even
weirder way i think i might actually
miss you huh and in an even weirder way
i want you guys to be my dad's that is
weirder yeah i got stuff i uh brought
you your box of dvds huh thank you
oh forgot about this one we never
watched captain corelli's mandolin
what the hell did you just say
captain crowley's mandolin say that to
my face
captain darling's panel there was a
movie about a mandolin and you kept it
from me for two months well i didn't
think it was any good it's just some
period piece what's that in grease oh my
goodness based on some dumb book
terribly sorry it has been a very trying
time yeah next thing you're gonna say
you wish we would watch leaving las
vegas a dark ponderous reflection on
alcoholism that earned cages oscar ah
what i told you the guy's got range all
right just let me do the talking here
okay i mean he's a lawyer i'm an
accountant and we speak the same
language i mean obviously
accountants are a little more a bad boy
but uh there's a respect there when will
this be over hey trevor i've been
talking to ron about estate planning and
he is here to do some good will
hunting
cause he has to drop a new will so yes i
understand yes do i thank you as i've
said before i just don't like puns oh
well my accountant friends seem to enjoy
mr swanson let's begin by filling out
this form listing your assets and
liabilities nice try
i'm not telling you how much money i
have where it's hidden or which precious
metals and or gemstones it may or may
not take the form of if you don't give
me the information i need there's
nothing i can do oh come on trevor where
there's a will
there's a way
i'm gonna say this one last time wyatt
check the account and crap at the door
yes sir i will
unintentional
i don't even need an exact number just
ballpark it that's all i need to get
started or i'm sure the state government
would love to use your money to hire
more bureaucrats maybe build a library
fine
a ballpark figure thank you god
holy
is this a joke another word for jokes is
lies i do not lie therefore i do not
joke mr swanson in a state of this size
means that your children would never
have to work a day in their lives this
is going to take some time trusts need
to be drawn tax shelters that's enough
i do not need some drawn-out legal
expedition to tell me what i knew when i
was eight here's my original will do
whatever lawyer nonsense you have to to
make it official and i will sign it good
day
wait
what are all these symbols
i was right not to be threatened by you
i had to do oh you had to junk your
jeans
but how could you betray your own kind
like this who taught you how to turn a
human inside out by reaching down their
throat and grabbing their butt from the
inside you did you got that right sister
and this is how you repay me oh spare me
this sanctimonious lecture you never
cared about me in the words of one of my
actual friends you're basic
it's a human insult it's devastating
you're devastated right now captain holt
has back-to-back meetings at one police
plaza today which means we have a
four-hour window before he checks any of
the security feeds but going out into
public is a huge risk so maybe let's go
over some self-defense techniques
oh
usually you warn somebody before you do
that raymond told me that the element of
surprise was crucial cool
so he's a great teacher but i will say
this if you're gonna do a throat punch
it is key that you say something cool
afterwards like
joke on that right but they're not
choking they're experiencing airway
trauma ooh how about better get some
corticosteroids to treat that laryngeal
fracture okay yeah that's very
informative and quite polite but maybe
add a dirt bag on the end but a dirt bag
is a useful part of a vacuum i don't see
how it's an insult all right you know
puncher's choice moving on we're gonna
need disguises and since we're going to
a public library the best way to fit in
is as scholars weird perverts yes weird
perverts is far better far better
[Music]
what is the bandwidth on the wi-fi here
we have much content to stream
you